it's a possible futures billions of
deaths we've got to stop you from a
no-show so what do we do first
we can still change the future
welcome to first one I have to prepare
the team for this crisis
[Music]
flash Tuesday October 8th extreme free
next day only on the CW app welcome back
everyone is Charlie we have brand new
flash footage brand-new Smallville
Superman crisis crossover footage to
break down everybody cues the Smallville
soundtrack I would put it in this video
if I didn't think that it would
immediately get claimed for audio we're
doing a new flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your best
Smallville Superman crossover theory on
the video the reason why we're getting
this new Smallville crossover footage
from crisis is because they actually
started filming the first episode of the
crossover so we don't know exactly how
many episodes Tom Welling and Erica
Durance are going to be in but she's
going to be in the crossover if it was
any question about that
that's why she's on set here they're on
the set of the Kent farm on their
version of Smallville
whatever the designation of their earth
is going to be because remember the
Smallville of supergirls earth is the
exact same farm where they filmed all
the Smallville episodes that was meant
to be a bit of a minor crossover but you
technically can't say that Smallville is
canon - the arrow verse until they
actually have the actors on the show
playing their characters from the
Smallville TV show which they're doing
now finally the very first episode of
the crossover will be the Supergirl
episode so I'm assuming that the footage
that they're filming here is going to
appear during the Supergirl first
episode of the crossover they tend to do
a lot of Superman stuff on the Supergirl
TV show so it makes sense that they
would do that and everyone's bummed out
about Michael Rosenbaum saying that he's
not going to be in the crossover that
could change he could be lying to us how
much would you freak out though if he's
been punking us this whole time and he
just shows up as wally west from the
Justice League animated TV show like hey
guys what's up why are you looking at me
funny
I'm Wally West we've got Burt Ward from
the 1966 Batman TV series playing I
think an older version of his Robin from
that show and then obviously the Kevin
Conroy Batman from the Batman the
Animated Series and Batman Beyond The
version of his character that he's
playing is meant to be really really old
that's why I'm saying Batman Beyond all
the new flash footage gives you a better
idea for how they're opening the season
with crisis on Infinite Earths in this
big multiverse level disaster but in the
new flash footage you see Barry getting
strapped into that Jay Garrick helmet by
another version of his mother you
finally see Jay Garrick standing behind
him so Jay Garrick confirmed for the
flash episode 1 this is
happening though after the monitor shows
up which seems like it's supposed to
happen at the beginning of the episode
in the footage they're staring at the
future newspaper and talking about how
can we stop this the monitor showing up
like he showed up for Oliver in the
arrow finale is the reason why they're
freaking out about this and iris says
okay what are we gonna do next Barry
just completely freaking out cue the
Smallville music again
somebody save Barry he has his Doctor
Strange Avengers infinity war moment
billions of possible futures billions of
deaths the reason why I think this
version of his mother is going to be
Joan Garrick Jay Garrick's wife from
Earth 3 is because pears tend to show up
in the same configurations across the
multiverse like usually a berry is
married to an iris of some sort on
another earth so it makes sense that at
Barry's dad Henry Allen married a woman
that looked like this then it makes
sense that Jay Garrick who's a version
of his father from another earth also
married a woman that looks like this
they just have different backstories and
their lives played out in a very
different way so she's probably like his
version of Tina McGee from the 90s flash
TV show and even though we have Jay
Garrick in this first episode they will
bring back 90s flash from Elseworlds for
the crisis on Infinite Earths episodes
so the whole of the flash first episode
is then learning about crisis in trying
to figure out how to avert Barry's death
really just looking at it from that
perspective we want to stop Barry from
disappearing which is really just a
continuation of last season's storyline
with Nora coming from the future to try
and stop this from happening the
brand-new character that we've been
seeing in all these trailers this person
here is called Chester Runk he is a
flash villain from the comics his
special power in the comics was
transporting matter from one universe to
another multiverse powers you can see
why that's important for their crisis on
Infinite Earths storyline this version
of the character seems like he's
live-streaming a science experiment that
probably has something to do with the
multiverse maybe it causes part of the
accident that you see everybody's
screaming about in all this footage like
you see all these people running through
the streets screaming you see Joe West
freaking out looking up at the sky and
then you see the particle accelerator
explode in the middle of the night so
maybe his experiment and what Barry's
trying to do to avert crisis sort of
interact with each other and that's what
causes this big explosion there is also
god speed during episode 1 - so because
they erased the future timeline that
Nora came from and that's where
initially got our Godspeed on the TV
show this version of Godspeed would have
to be somebody completely different
maybe Chester runks experiment and
whatever Barry's trying to do with the
Speed Force to avert his death has
something to do with this version of
Godspeed showing up during the episode
but a lot of this footage of him getting
thrown around and this big fight might
be from that there's also other villains
stuff that it seems like it's happening
in the episode like you see killer frost
completely freaking out trying to stab
Barry then you see her powers going all
crazy you see a couple other new
characters fighting in an office we
can't tell who they are and we get our
brand-new version of Harrison wells
ziplining in Indiana jones-style loves
Cisco's reaction oh good another angry
one you can see iris there just being
surprised by everything what the hell is
going on with this brand new version of
Harrison wells we don't know which earth
he comes from we just know that he won't
have a weird accent this year so he'll
be speaking a little bit more like earth
to Harrison wells
but we don't exactly know what his
backstory is going to be he's just gonna
be a little more adventurous than
previous versions of the character the
whole thing with killer frost freaking
out in this episode probably has
something to do with her special
storyline something happens to her she
gets into an accident on one of the
saves that they go on during the episode
and it causes her to sort of question
the nature of her relationship with
everyone else so most of danielle
Panabaker 'he's time at least during the
first half of the season on the flash is
going to be spent as the killer frost
character you won't see quite as much
caitlin as you do killer frost
I think that'll wind up being way more
fun she has the cool new costume so
you'll be seeing her walking around
doing killer frost stuff most of the
season there's not a whole lot of the
blood work villain in this version of
the trailer but we'll probably see him
show up either in a tag at the end of
the episode or something to sort of set
up what's going on with his character or
something related to this accident in
the episode and you'll never believe
while I was making this video they also
just confirm that Huntress from the
birds of prey 2002 TV show is coming
back that's right they're gonna canonize
birds of prey I don't know if they're
also getting Barbara Gordon from that
show because she played Oracle / Batgirl
she was Oracle and present-day this is
just like a brief clip of that if you've
never watched it you don't need to watch
that show though my name is Alfred
Pennyworth
and I have a story to tell the many
years in the city of new Gotham a secret
war raged by night unknown to the
everyday world and battle for the very
heart of the city was waged between
Batman and Joker one night the final
battle was formed and Joker lost Joker's
revenge was taken not on Batman himself
but on the ones he loved Helena Kyle
didn't know that her father was Batman
nor did she know that her mother had
once been catwalk he was pretty raw that
was like the Hot Topic version of birds
of prey the birds of prey movie will be
a thousand times better it's actually
gonna be all rated that's right all
rated at birds of prey movie in the DC
Universe the really good news though is
that because they're actually filming
the crossover episodes now we'll be
getting more previews and promos behind
the scenes stuff I'll try to do as many
videos for that as possible and I will
try to include big Easter eggs from the
different shows in the videos that I do
because I won't be able to do videos for
every single episode of every single TV
show don't freak out if you don't watch
every single TV show you don't have to
watch everything to understand what's
going on during the crossover I'll cover
most of that important stuff during my
crossover videos so don't freak out if
you only watch one or two of the shows
you should be good to go if you haven't
been watching Titans either they're
actually gonna be doing Nightwing in the
next couple of episodes
the Titans finale where they're gonna be
doing a lot of Jason Todd red hood stuff
big coincidence that'll be happening
around the same time as the DC TV crisis
on Infinite Earths
crossover episodes it'll be really busy
in October November in December but it's
also much cool stuff that's coming up
Rick and Morty's coming back The
Watchmen HBO series is starting I'll be
doing episode videos for that then we
have The Witcher Netflix coming with
Henry Cavill Superman himself that might
be December then we have the Mandalorian
Star Wars TV series so as long as you
have alerts enabled for my channel you
should see all the videos when I post
them I'm really excited about some of
this big stuff that's coming up
congratulations Jack strange or the
giveaway winner from my last big video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details yes I
do think that Oliver will get a pep talk
from the older version of Bruce Wayne
and some of these other supermen he's
gonna have a lot of scenes with a lot of
different supermen
everybody click here for the other big D
CTB arrow flash crisis trailer and click
here to learn why Kevin Feige in marble
are making the Star Wars movie after
Star Wars Episode nine thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]